now the reason why is it's important
that you learn to do this it's because
you're the most photographed people in
the world
the Charles W Howard Santa Clause school
is the world's oldest Santa Clause
school it is here to help Santa's become
[Music]
the Santa Claus school teaches the
Santa's how to build that Santa spirit
in their heart what you do it's not how
far you go in life it's who you walk
with who you walk with that's nice
somewhere around five thousand Santa's
have come through the Santa school since
1986 this year we've had 200 Santa's at
Santa's school and 25% of those were
mrs. Claus's so it is something you're
behind me
yes that is mrs. Claus Karen
[Music]
what hit me was that the kids won't
remember what they got for Christmas but
they're going to remember their visit
with Santa I wouldn't change a thing
with that if that natural hair is taken
care of it can look really good and so
can a real natural hair from a wig
master but you know a lot of these
fellows are from my generation the
hippie generation so they had that hair
back when they were younger so they just
bring it back it wasn't until I became
Santa Claus that I actually grew up my
DNA changed dNA stands for december nice
attitude santa jerry has fun in life so
I'm sure he has fun being Santa yeah
baby
he's uh he's a carrot you leave your ego
in the sleigh so everyone is more heart
centered and they offer their
experiences or tricks to help you become
a better Santa because you never learn
at all I'm not worthy the simple
grasshopper here I help I pick out one
or two other rookie Santa's and give
them tips on how to be the best senator
they can be part of what I was asking
him about was the kids that are afraid
of you and how you deal with that now
they're standing
they're above you their blood pressures
would have drop learning the Santa
spirit and going through the process we
do makes you understand that there
really is a Santa Claus there's a Santa
Claus spirit and that spirit is an all
200 of these students that are here
today
[Music]
[Music]
you